my name is Professor Andrew Przewalski's
and in my humble opinion technology
addiction is a myth casual use of the
term addiction has a very real effect of
potentially trivializing how we talk
about addiction more broadly we might
say a popular game app or streaming
series is addictive but what do we
really mean when we use that word are we
seriously ik waiting this kind of
behavior with a problem with drinking or
taking drugs what we really mean is the
activity is fun it's engaging its
immersive and it's enjoyable we know the
amount of dopamine that's released when
you do something like have sex eat food
or play video games
it's kind of a pretty narrow band but
taking drugs like cocaine ecstasy or in
fetta means has a much larger impact
something that not many people know is
that technology addiction itself started
as a bit of a practical joke in the mid
1990s the American psychiatrist dr. Ivan
Goldberg grew frustrated with how
psychiatry was medicalizing everyday
life he wanted to use the internet as an
example he took symptoms from gambling
disorder and substance abuse disorder
and he pushed them together to kind of
illustrate how silly the manual ization
of everyday life had become here we are
20 years later talking about video game
addiction internet addiction and
smartphone addiction as if they're
they're real own things along with
checklists acronyms and media headlines
though headlines might seem very sure
about the addictive potential of
Technology the actual research itself is
a bit of a mess we're not really sure if
technology might cause problems in
people's lives or if those who already
have problems in their lives gravitate
to using technology and less healthy
ways one of the most worrying things is
because there isn't a lot of good
evidence in hand
there are a lot of people trying to sell
the general public on some big ideas at
the very least this means that people
are selling books they're going on chat
shows
they're kind of being influencers but at
the worst it means that some people are
taking advantage
they're running for-profit clinics
they're using methods of treatment that
haven't been either standardized or
validated or shown to help people in
some cases we have people who are
running clinics publishing research on
technology addiction and not disclosing
that they themselves are profiting
directly from treating technology
addiction what's currently missing from
the debates and the worries about
technology addiction is a historic
perspective in the 1980s we were very
worried about Dungeons and Dragons
playing role-playing games and involved
young people's imaginations we were
worried that they would lose connection
with the real world that they would
engage in satanic rituals then in the
late 80s and early 90s we became very
worried about rap music and violent
video games we thought that maybe they
changed young people drove them to
commit violent acts we did stop worrying
about rap music Dungeons & Dragons or
video games because of new empirical
evidence we stopped worrying about them
because our anxieties shifted from those
fields from those topics to things like
the internet and online games so as
scientists as psychologists and
researchers we need to ask ourselves is
there really something special about
technology or is this a new panic that
we have to grapple with thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon